ん
悩み事がないように見える男
日本第37位はじめしゃちょー
この男にも
一つの悩みがあっ
した弾み社長今どこにいるかといいますと
3億円のお家のトレーニングラームにいる
んですけれどもご覧くださいこの設備結構
いろんな器具を買わせてもらいました
タータくさんありますね今回の動画皆さん
量を聞いてくださいね
このトレーニングん
いいえいいえ
ってしまいました勝ち合致この
トレーニング自分にあるもの全部売りたい
と思ってます理由説明させてもらっている
シズネもらったんトレーニングとは何か
軽く価値ってだけの人間からすると本当に
何か日々の積み重ねなんですよほぼ東京
だったが先週とか様とフードれたに良い
設備があってもその場にいないという意味
がない日々が積み重ねられないずーっと俺
がた静岡ギターいるんだったら全然一自由
必要よしっかり街でありたいと思うてるん
ですけどももう察せですなりヶ月の中の1
週間とかチーズを変えなかったらさあ本当
にいい君の積み重ねのこの部屋阿部にある
ファイラー
日々の積み重ねられにあるって思ってだっ
たら筋トレしてそして多いやっぱブーム
作ってねブーム内容か絶対これなんかその
まま捨てると思っていない必要な人がい
たらぜひ入りたいだと思って今回ツェン
から多く村かけさせていただきます運ゲ
受けることだってこれは1円で買えるかも
知れ労組生んだけど止めなければいいじゃ
ないかいます山木冬のボロボロだった
こっちは全然問題なく使えるんですけどヘ
が新品でわけでもないしおすすめできる人
は何かとりあえず筋トレしたいんですが
あんまりものとか気にしないですよなんと
なくちょっと筋トレしてみたいっていう人
はぜひとももうちょい参加したらいいかな
と
頭を全部ちゃん使いが使えるのでそこ安心
してくださいからちょうだいさが良くない
よっていうかついていろいろを含めたら
まあ一致員からのスタートとさせて
いただきますこの船それ動画に付けたい
からもっとはいという意味で人体に何を
打っていくと紹介していきたいと思います
でいきましょう
まずはまずはこの床でちょっと今汚れてる
人も結構多いですけどね陳皮も結構ある
まあまあ聞けるくらいですから何っている
ちょっとサイズは分からないです結構数
あるので程よくように使って頂けると
嬉しいです26ないぐらい新品もあります
これを楽たくさんのご希望に沿って方や
柔軟に対応させて頂きたいと思っており
ますや見ていきましょうまずはなぜにも
これでしょランニングマシーンこれさえ
あればそっと店来ていいからこれ13差で
まずやせるための脂肪も屋さんということ
でこれは結構使い込んだやつですちょっと
戦闘はついてるんですけども全然問題なく
買えるので水ではこちらでこれなんか色々
聞いとり使えるやつでちょっとずっと
パターンせたりしてですね別の企業を決定
的三方が俺が不滅の初16だから
2m 20がやるからちょっと大きい
森福やってたのはまあ
[音楽]
ね聞くねマジで聞くこれああーー
屋根開けたくなかってきちゃ錦水ところで
いるするよでからこれは普通に
いいやあと倒れたラーニング個取ってた
気付い圧痕黒と赤でねクリムゾンレッド
トレーニング自分インズあってる
パーティーゴールド中3 o
そこがじゃあ今回で回復ということで赤黒
で岐阜市丸自分になると思いますこれ叱っ
たら次
茶にこれユーザーとっていうのを持って
るっていうこれも赤黒とマグロですよ
それぞれ後輩が入ってたんだけど俺は1回
と分かりませんこれだけ凝っちゃっあー
これもかなりいいと思いますよねこれが
一番なんかをものだよミリアサ凧の量だけ
られかわかんないけど結局買えば理想的
これもでやったねやった爪上でこうやって
ありますうち女でしたよ
[音楽]
はいいねぇ自分で持つ帰りますので足も
行きますと
ともいけちゃうといっ
まぁ使い方ほんと様々ですけども結局
ウエイトを使う取りに行きくださいこちら
も1位から絶対やって全部含めてちゃんと
50音順であの郡足場でトレーニング自分
を売りたいちょっと小箱のセットですはい
いい感じの金貨作りたかったからそんなに
重くない奴こういうたば20キロぐらいな
んだとこれやるだけでも相当腕は
いい感じになる台車がやっぱりオーディオ
な処理がセットでダンベルを大津があり
ますのでこれもしっかりとらせていただき
ますああこれねこれを述べ汁頭です
あー
聞く歌てねこれじゃあの方こないんです
けどもここが残念ですからポスターを
作れるんですね
だこれね
ちょいー
ゲージアソスも
ん
うわぁ
んウオロクねー10万円の直近がまだ桜
でこの大松使えるじゃあ幹線でちょっと
スプレーで若干が多くなっているのが残念
というですけど学校はずっとご様子を
いただけますと品質には問題ないので
例がですねバーベルって音が多くて危ない
のでロックされると思いますねこれで
しっかりロックされてるんですけども
[音楽]
片方が9と
ついてない
オージャンクイーンジャンプないこれは
多分
ぶりに出したりしけん2匹がってるので
走りたいよアプリものとさせていただき
ますあったという船から
じゃないとつけちゃぴこあげてもいいん
ですかね
1個と言わず日本今者 hiro どこだ
この自分やってるから助けにクリムゾン
なんで作曲家クリムゾンなどバスれたこの
ため2個付けさせていただきます o 脚
スター合わせれておりましたとっておきの
アイテムをつけておきます大
こちら一生の四座ナットの音階をつけさせ
て頂きましてお値段なんと変わらず1円
からのスタートになっております少しなん
とお客さんでやっていると思いますでしょ
僧侶 war
私もつでございますリーアーマー値
マジでこれは白元者を引っ張っくるんです
ねはいというわけで本日初めて所が愛用し
ていたこのそれにグルーまるごとせて
オークションで売らせていただきますので
ぜひチェックしてみてください皆さんが
落ちたりますいやーこれ全部もしかして
サイン
はその方次第ですけどのお客様もし
よろしいというと出ればサインなどはもう
進んで行かせていただきたい方もすごい
ねー本当にその1名様のためにずベゼを
すべて
ますのでよろしくお願い致します
[音楽]
はいだけトレーニング自分の目標なんです
けれども業炎で準備が出来ましたちょっと
オークションだしたことはなくて良いの
ずっと不手際があるかもしれませんけれど
も必要ヤフオクの方で出させていただき
ましてこの動画が出てから1週間期間設け
ましたそれ中華でなくラックスっていうん
だっけ
何も版ない僕だしたツールがそこに
どんどんそのこの金額だった家庭4つ一つ
乗っております1周監督は水時間とか
ヒンジパパは実際にヤフーオークションの
設定を見てもらってくださいこの動画で台
でどんな風に普及がある角ばって
申し合わせてきたので
voodoo
セリアエウソンのかと思ってないですけど
ただ本当に僕は手紙曲げたいっていう
気持ちが大きい
ただと言われたからなので1円から
スタートということで以前からちゃんと
トレーニングジム意識をオークションあっ
ていただきますぜひ筋肉つけたい人よかっ
たら是非見てみてくださいねほんとによる
要望を聞きしたいのでラク三世成功された
方
[音楽]
voodoo